What is it about dogs that brings us so much joy Oh
Sydney the resistance joining a party for my dog. No, I went to a doggie wedding last weekend and it was like
surprisingly emotional
Maybe it's because dogs are the most adorable creatures in the planet
Looks so angry and happy at the same time
Listen to me baby, that's all I think whatever it is dogs mean the world to us. I wanna help you find your dog
Catch it you look absolutely beautiful today
Every spot that you sniff on this entire wall is the same thing just
Dogs open their hearts to us to love and to be loved and I find that beautiful
Let me buy you dinner first pal